emprunté une voiture ça ne veut rien
dire surtout pas quand on a 15 ans est
passible de trois ans d'emprisonnement
la série son arrivée à strasbourg et ils
sont d'accord pour s'occuper de chérif
et à son père aussi qu'il est encore là
bas on qui pourra compter sur son stage
je suis sûr si j'ai mon nom je savais
chantier l'acceptent et ont parlé au
père est ici pourquoi t'es pas chez lui
alors puisque c'est trop petit
j'ai un vison
pourquoi
c'est en tant que tu sois tu nous
prévient
un mec qui cartonne en ce moment j'ai
pas pour qui il se prend mais ils
veulent comprendre qu'ils ont à nous
font mal
budan tu peux te cacher on ne la bande à
lyon
m
longtemps par la personne
jamais et
cela me flatte alors pourquoi t'es fais
tu veux quoi tu joues ta merde partout
c'est simple si tu vas faire tu
apprenais tutelle des banques c'est ce
que je veux faire quoi
je montais des morts de ta vie
à nos amours je trouve nm
elle aurait eu